you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news live from cot 26 in glasgow
today
into extra time the cop 26 summit
carries on this evening as the
conference president says critical
issues remain outstanding
there's widespread condemnation of the
summit from those on the front line of
the climate crisis who say the draft
agreement is a bare minimum of what's
needed
a future still built on fossil fuels we
meet the people in india whose lives and
livelihoods depend on coal
and the wildlife under threat in
madagascar from deforestation and
poaching as the climate crisis leads to
the destruction of precious habitats
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show live from the heart of cop 26 in
glasgow as the summit here continues
past its scheduled end time of 6 pm well
this morning a draft agreement was
published it had weakened language on
fossil fuels compared to a previous
version but did provide more finance for
poorer countries to adapt to climate
change and included a request for all
nations to strengthen their plans for
cutting emissions
but it's not signed off yet with nearly
200 parties yet to agree on the final
wording of
the outcome so let's go live now to our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter who's here in glasgow too
and hannah what's happening now then how
close are the various parties to an
agreement
well after that closing plenary session
and we heard from 38 different countries
all putting forward things they did
agree with and things they did not
they they kind of came out and scattered
the four corners of this massive uh
complex where we are here for cop 26 and
they went into individual meeting rooms
there have been a flurry of intense
negotiations around a couple of key
points and they are the same points that
have been haunting
this summit progress being made on
adaptation finance for poor nations
progress being made on perhaps just
perhaps keeping language around phasing
out fossil fuel subsidies and unabated
coal that's a surprise progress being
made i think on agreeing to a timeline
to come back by the end of next year or
early 2023 with better commitments to
reduce carbon emissions but there are
some areas where progress is slow
that is around the issue of poor
countries being paid for loss and damage
associated with climate change really
difficult to get america in particular
to agree to a sort of open-ended
repayment system that is being pushed
for by the poorer nations and still some
wrangling about how all the countries
here are going to report on an annual
basis the progress they are making that
might sound all very technical but these
things have continued to be an issue in
the months and weeks before this summit
they are an issue right now alok sharma
the president of this summit has to hold
his nerve now
and bring consensus together because
the end of the summit is nigh and the
clock is ticking for him to get
everybody to agree to these crucial and
difficult issues
yeah there's still a lot of work to do
the texas on the table i think is
it for where we were
um
i think it's the best
possible
um output for this cop
but it's the bare minimum that we need
to leave with certainly on on the
ambition front and the mitigation front
gonna wrap up by 6 pm or are we in for a
long night
i have my sleeping bag
we've got a lot of work to do tonight
where in particular
we heard it in the room
adaptation finance loss and damage
just bringing bringing the ambition from
developing nations and developed nations
together to make sure that everybody
gets a better deal if there is an
improvement in the text on finance
will that derail this agreement
there will be we're still moving
still moving i could get stuck but i
think we
we're just in for a long night it's
always like this
warnings of a long night what next well
a new cover agreement text which may not
be the final version i think this is
going to be a very long 24 hours
indeed hannah thanks very much indeed
well our science and technology editor
tom clark has all the latest on today's
developments now
for many the time for quiet negotiation
has passed
after 12 days of patient u.n process
demonstrators staged a symbolic walkout
at the lack of ambition from leaders at
cop26
governments aren't listening to us and
we want to say that the outcomes here
are not going to be just
want to see action where everywhere all
the demands are met and the fossil fuels
are kept in the ground
we've got to be going a lot further and
a lot faster at this point there's a
massive disconnect between what these
activists are calling for what's
actually being reflected in the text
being negotiated here in glasgow the
elements of it are actually quite
radical as far as the un process goes
question is will those elements survive
to the end after pulling an all-nighter
corralling groups of divergent
negotiators cop president alok sharma
now has to rush nearly 200 ministers to
agree positions before time runs out we
need to all get back to work
let us drive progress and forge
consensus and as so many of you have
said the eyes of the world are honest
key parts of the negotiating text about
cutting coal and finding more finance
for poor countries have been watered
down but their meaning survives
and so far no country wants to be seen
as an obstacle and many may even
compromise more we've actually proposed
many of the uh of the of the solutions
that have been put on the table that
have allowed the negotiations to move
forward uh so uh i don't see how one
could believe that we would be
uh we we could be an obstacle to
anything quite to the contrary but
differences potentially intractable ones
remain the summit's aim to keep 1.5
alive hinges on countries agreeing to
return next year with more ambition to
cut carbon but that's still a red line
for some who won't give up fossil fuels
and for others who want more time
i think that the arrangements should be
based on the framework and provisions of
the paris agreement to allow parties
space and time to implement their ndc's
one thing that could bring china and
others round is more money for the
developing world where it has many
interests
the u.s has definitely thrown its
diplomatic weight at cop
but not its wallet special envoy kerry
what progress has been made where are
they
i think we're making progress we're
doing what negotiators should do we're
negotiating are you worried about
finance we will get there no not
[Applause]
outside some protesters tried to climb
the miles of fencing surrounding cop26
many negotiators inside must know how
they feel
scaling the seemingly impossible but
with genuine hope it's not all in vain
tom clark sky news glasgow
let's take a look now at some of the
other reaction to today's draft
agreement from cop 26 and indigenous
environmentalists have criticized the
climate summit
twenty-year-old takaya blaney from the
klamin nation in british columbia
represents the indigenous people's
constituency
cop26 is a performance
it's an illusion constructed to salvage
capitalist economies
rooted in resource extraction and
colonialism
i didn't come here to fix the agenda i
came here to disrupt it
we will outlive these empires
that were built on our genocide
our ancestors survived many apocalypses
and when we talk about this climate
apocalypse you know we're going to
survive it too but it's gonna come from
the people
[Music]
[Applause]
a group of island nations are pushing
for higher climate ambition in the cop
26 talks they say the final deal needs
to include stronger action to mitigate
the loss and damage caused by climate
change
to level up not fall back
in this final stretch we're going to
fight hard for the ambition in here and
to build on this text and fight for
greater ambition particularly on loss
and damage we will continue to champion
1.5 which is our coalition's north star
fossil fuel subsidies must end we must
double adaptation finance from current
levels loss and damage is too central
for us to settle for workshops
the kenyan environment minister told the
summit two million people in his country
are facing starvation due to droughts he
added that african countries have done
their bit within the limited resources
that are within their means
for kenya and africa 1.5 degrees
is actually 3 plus
degree centigrade
this is what we lived in
this is what our communities live
through
and that is why in kenya and in africa
we cry we bleed
we bleed when it rains
we cry
when it doesn't rain
so for us ambition 1.5 is not just it's
not a statistic
it is a matter of life
and death
madagascar is one of the world's lowest
emitters of carbon dioxide but one of
the countries most severely affected by
the climate crisis
it's facing the world's first climate
change famine after a drought lasting
four years
people are taking desperate measures
just to survive leading to severe
consequences for the natural environment
well our special correspondent alex
crawford reports now from madagascar
[Music]
it's the call of the singing lemur
recorded and played out on the phone
he's holding
the indras are the only mammal besides
humans who use patterned rhythm it's
their way of communicating
[Music]
within seconds there's a cacophony in
response to the recording from the
lemurs all above us in the rainforest
the guides are monitoring the lima
numbers the singing primates are on the
verge of extinction in the wild
threatened by hunting and habitat loss
exacerbated by climate change that call
had an amazing effect they're actually
they're actually replying
[Music]
very noisy
too much i make this image fall right
he's calling it reasons work this is
after you're fighting
yes
very special yes until right 10
kilometers you can during his
communication like that
kristin is head of the guardians of this
forest the protectors of the enormously
rich natural treasures living here and
only found here but they are very few in
number
and look at the scale of this forest
they're trekking through this is a
relatively small one just 750 hectares
but underneath the canopy there is
wildlife plants and insects you'll find
nowhere else on earth
but the deforestation is happening at
such a rate that studies suggest all of
these eastern forests could disappear
within 50 years and with them the unique
treasures in them
people collect beliefs to export i don't
know for what what kind of essential
oils but until now that is a big problem
in our forest here
and we make a patrol like this to to
interrupt and to stop completely hundred
percent
look
the lemurs survive on these trees if
these trees disappear the lemurs
disappear
and you can only find these lemurs and
there are over 100 different species of
them here in madagascar in the wild and
they are the most
endangered
mammals
in the world at the moment
they're trying to grow new trees endemic
to this area but these are small
beginnings and it takes time they don't
have with extreme weather hampering
those efforts
normally this is the one of the rain
seasons but no
there's no rain this is i can say this
is the problem with the climate change
they call it slash and burn almost half
of this forest has been left degraded
due to this practice clearing land for
crops and it has a devastating impact
among those killed almost to the point
of extinction is the golden mantella
frog all the country's frogs and they
have more than 300 different species
play a vital role
if there is a place without frog
there must be a big problems of malaria
because frog eat insect
date mostly
mosquitoes and ants
so if if
if places have not any frog they must
have a big problems of some disease
but the forest guardians have their work
cut out for them
making notes and taking gps locations of
fell trees isn't halting the destruction
and the locals pounce when they know the
patrols are off duty it is really really
very
bad because
we are growing more trees during
every year but the people the stealing
cutting
so that's why we need help each big
festival independence days christmas
days and the new year's
people because all is it dancing at home
like like he said the world is a cutting
prophet because missing no people
no patrol
poverty is driving up poaching and even
eating their unique wildlife as people
struggle in the face of unusually
extreme weather
this fat-tailed dwarf lemur which looks
in a very sorry state was rescued by the
guides when it became sick after being
held as a pet
the only primate known to hibernate
kristen and his daughter decide they
have to release the lima back into the
wild how do you feel about saying
goodbye to him now
sad little bitty
up little bit because bikini and you
still looking me oh you
it
touched my heart
but now it's got the chance of survival
so much of madagascar's natural
treasures are being robbed of that
alex crawford sky news madagascar
one of the key announcements from the
cop 26 summit was a commitment from more
than 40 countries to phase out the use
of coal power one of the most polluting
fossil fuels but for many of the poorest
people around the world it remains an
essential part of everyday life
more than 70 percent of all india's
power comes from coal-fired power plants
and the mines that produce the fossil
fuel offer both official and unofficial
work to those who would otherwise have
nothing skies caterina vertosi reports
now from the city of jarria where the
end of coal is nowhere near insight
[Applause]
they are here every day from dawn until
dark dodging bulldozers and tipper
trucks for this
what these local villagers want is coal
and they'll trespass onto government
mines to get it
it's terrifying to watch as even very
young children race towards lorries
unloading piles of mine pit debris
sifting through the remains
to steal whatever little chunks of coal
they
that's 50 pence for this enormous risk
but people do it because they're
desperate
and we spot even more people on their
way
[Music]
[Music]
this is happening in the plain view of
all the people who are officially
working here you know they can see what
is happening and it happens every single
day and although police we are told come
and periodically chase people off
tacitly they accept it because they know
if people aren't allowed to do this
however dangerous it might be they've
got nothing left
coal is the fuel that sustains india's
poorest
it's cheap accessible and here plentiful
the industry employs many hundreds of
thousands like kishore pasuan who's
worked at this government mine for 35
years
foreign
despite india's new 2017 net zero date
there's no clear targets for coal and
workers at this mine tell us they've
been told to extract more
because although india has ambitious
plans for renewable energy lifting
millions out of poverty means power now
and lots of it
when the world is saying we've got to
stop burning things we've got to stop
using coal is there a way we can do that
and balance that without sacrificing
these communities
do mining or don't do it mining but they
will do their mining by their own so
without coal
the entire area cannot exist
and as toxic as this air is the
villagers living next to these mines
don't want to move
the coal dust is filthy
clings to their lungs but this is
everything to them
foreign
[Music]
cop leaders tell us the end of coal is
in sight
but here it will place a huge demand on
people
who care more about their family's
short-term survival than the global
climate crisis
[Applause]
catherine of autopsy sky news in juria
india
well we're discussing all the day's
developments now with fahana yamin who's
international lawyer and climate
activist who's been to virtually every
big climate summit over the past 30
years often as a negotiator and carvey
gillampur from the center for climate
and energy solutions and former senior
adviser to the u.n secretary general's
climate team so just the people we need
to be talking to i can't wait to you
first of all nearly an hour after the
the scheduled end of this summit where
are we what's happening now
well i think we're we're really in the
end game of the of the cop and as
expected the
cop presidencies put forward a text it
was a revision from the first version
and we had a what's called a stock
taking plenary with many ministers from
around the world present to take a first
view of that text and from my
perspective i think that the the two
main messages that came out of there
were first of all everybody spoke about
the importance of keeping 1.5 alive
that's definitely the new standard and
also everybody said that they could work
with the tech so i think that's a really
good sign at this stage in the co-op
would you agree with that for hana
because there have been problems around
finance around carbon markets around the
mention even of coal so do you think
that they've got over those particular
problems
um i think that you know they've given
very clear instructions to the cop
presidency team to come back with
revisions um and those big issues are
very thorny we've been dealing with them
for a long long time so i think there's
a long night ahead
possibly a night and a half i think yeah
a night and a half so when do you think
it's going to wrap up i i i can't like
unless money is put on the table for
like loss and damage unless there's a
very clear pathway to parties coming
back year on year to complete the the
gap to bridge the gap that there now is
between 1.5 and 2.4 which is where we
are i don't see uh you know delegations
from the global south giving up well
that that's interesting and carvey if we
do end up with a document that looks a
bit like the last draft that we've seen
can this cop be deemed a success has 1.5
being kept alive in your view i think we
heard from minister steele on your show
just a few moments ago who's been right
in the heart of those negotiations and
who is from a vulnerable uh developing
country
yes and and he's he i think he captured
it well that this is probably the best
that we could get but it's the the least
that we can leave here with so i mean to
borrow
what others have said i think 1.5 would
be alive but on on life support so the
work would really need to start after
this cop to to really accelerate
ambition and as others are saying
including fahana
and many developing countries that we
really need to come back on an annual
basis and revise ambition more
frequently and that last draft document
did include that request for countries
to come back so how important is that if
that stays in and does that mean that
actually we can only really judge the
success of this summit in a year's time
in cop 27 in egypt well countries that
have not revised their
ndc's their national action targets in
line with 1.5 absolutely must come back
and put further offers on the table of
what they will do otherwise it it will
be a travesty if they don't do that
between now and cop 27 they don't have
to wait until december they can do it
any time now
the science is clear
the economics of switching to renewables
and away from fossil fuels is clear
it's very clear that you know we've been
subsidizing polluters for a long time
and that must end we must end too i'm
afraid for hana yaman and kave gillampur
thanks both very much indeed
so don't forget there's a new episode of
climate cast every day from cop26 you
can find them all wherever you normally
get your podcast from
and you may already be watching this on
our pop-up channel but if not you can
see uninterrupted coverage from cop26
including tomorrow we're here a day over
the scheduled end 9 a.m to 6 p.m on
channel 525 sky glass channel 505. but
that's it from me for now goodbye
[Music]